I should probably start my name is um
Stravinsky from what from research and
I'll be talking about basic and formula
regions so in Mathematica 10 we have
several new types of region introduced
and we have computation over the regions
so a region is a subset of RN for some N
and so we we have four types of regions
the basic regions this are special type
of defined region act like full region
empty region point line triangle
tetrahedron so this correspond to two
basic geometric figures so here's here's
the full list of regions that are
available in our and for arbitrary and
then we have certain basic regions that
are available only in dimension one
that's interval can be used as a region
in our one regions in our two so these
are simple planar geometric figures and
we have a few regions that are only
valid in r3 so here they are the second
type of regions is formula regions so
it's implicit region or parametric
region so it's either region defined by
implicit equations inequalities or bar
parametric system with equations on a
collision parameters as well so these
are the two types of formula regions
that we have then we can have derived
regions so these are regions that we
construct from other regions either
through boolean operations or
Cartesian products or transformations
and inverse transformation or also a we
can take there's we have an operator for
boundary of a region and the fourth type
of region which is type that I once
talked about but let me mention it is
our the mesh regions to the simple link
regions I'll be talking about are the
first first three types of regions so
first basic region so visualization four
basic regions is very easy since basic
regions can simply be used in graphics
and graphics 3d so that includes the the
newly added in version 10 regions like
triangle or half line so half line in
principle is an infinite region but for
visualization we can use it in graphics
and it will find a finite range over
with which to plot it and the same thing
for 3d graphics we can use ellipsoid and
conical region and simplex in 3d and and
we got immediately the plot of those
regions
so four-point membership membership four
basic regions so if we can use element
with constant points this will just
evaluate to true or false for for
membership testing and if there are
symbolic parameters then elements just
stays on evaluated in and can be used as
an assertion that the symbolic point
belongs to a region however we have a
function region member which would
explicitly give formulas for region
membership for symbolic regions and
symbolic points dimension properties of
basic regions so here is a simplex in
four dimensional space so the embedding
dimension will be the dimension of the
space in which the region is embedded so
here it is four and this is always a
simple structure of check so so if we
compute in region embedding dimension is
always immediate now the dimension of
region is is that the actual dimension
of the region as a set so this region is
is a simplex spanned by for a final
independent points so it will have
dimension three right so it's lower than
the dimension of embedding space and the
dimension of region requires non-trivial
computation in general but for the basic
region we usually have some very simple
ways of computing the dimension for
instance here we just compute the rank
of a certain matrix so this is fast
compared to formula region when
computing the dimension would be really
complicated thing
now bounce four basic region so that
back on we can ask whether it's a
bounded region and yes it is and we can
compute the bounds
so here the the bounds for so this is
the pair of bounds for the first
variable for the second variable and for
the third variable and we can plot it so
we have a bounding box for protocol and
again if we work with basic regions that
usually is very fast because we have
formulas for for the special regions
your distance properties for basic
region so we have three functions for
computing distance properties we can
region distance will compute a distance
of a point from a region region nearest
will compute the nearest point in the
region to a given point and sienten
distance is the same as distance if the
point is outside the region but if the
point is inside the region then it will
give the distance from the point with a
compliment of the region so it would be
negative inside and it's a big negative
negative inside the region so let me
show it so here we have this point is
now inside that a trajeron so sign
distance is negative distance is zero
and we can move the point outside and so
now it's below the region and now the
distance is equal to the sine distance
and and this is the nearest point in the
region it's in the middle of of the
bottom face of the region here it's now
it's on the on the edge it's in the
corner
so for many of the basic regions that
are closed-form formulas for distance
and nearest so here we can we can start
with a disc with symbolic radius where
it's actually it's a quarter of a disc
with symbolic radius and symbolic point
and we got formulas for for the distance
so let me here show a little digression
about piecewise functions so we have a
piecewise function like this how do you
how do we get a condition conditions and
and values from from the function we
have an internal function for this and
one more thing to to note is that we
there is one piecewise object in
Mathematica but internally there are two
types of piecewise functions there is an
order less piecewise function and then
there is the general piecewise function
so in the general this wise function we
don't do not know whether the conditions
are disjoint or not so we have to
evaluate all conditions in order to
decide what the value of the piecewise
function is and for the general
piecewise function the last coefficient
will be true the Rastas condition will
be true so that we always get the last
value although internally for some
functions we actually know the
information that all conditions are
disjoint and to figure out which
piecewise function we we have at a given
moment we can use interval from
piecewise and if it displays the last
condition and the last condition is not
true it's some condition that that means
that all conditions are guaranteed to be
disjoint and therefore we can for
instance reorder piecewise cases in any
way we please the evaluation will be the
same so here here's the little
digression and so now that we have the
the piecewise conditions
separated we can plot the regions
corresponding to to each of the
condition and they are indeed disjoint
and these are these are the regions in
which we have different ways of
computing the nearest point so here the
nearest point is this is our region
water of a circle and this in this
region the nearest point will be on this
part this region the nearest point will
be in this vertex this region it will be
on this part of the boundary and so on
and we can do the similar thing in 3d so
we have transitions for finding the
nearest point to attract children and
the point it has a symbolic coordinate
so we get piecewise function again we
can compute the conditions in value and
the values which I will not show because
this is computing this this takes about
a minute so I'll just show that the
picture again we have regions in in r3
where in where we have specific formula
for forgetting the nearest point
no measure properties of basic regions
so for most basic region computing
measure and centroid will be done by
using closed-form formulas so again it's
fast and it can be done with symbolic
parameters so for instance we have a
tetrahedron with all parameters symbolic
and we can request the measure here it
is and the centroid just arithmetic mean
of of the vertices or here it we can
compute measure of radius R Boeing the
59 five dimensional space so we have
formulas for all these there is no
computation involved and for we can
integrate over basic regions now there
is some computation involved but but
what we have special special formulas
against our special code for integrating
polynomial
mainly polynomials over special region
serves of the three first we can
integrate the polynomial over five DLF
so it or hear it if we integrate over a
region of dimension D we will use d
dimensional the ballot measures so we
have circle in r2 but we will use here
one dimensional nature because circle
has dimension 1 so we get expected 2 pi
integrating one circle and we can use
vector variables so dimensionality of
variables is determined from the
embedding dimensions of regions so we
have triangle in r2 and a ball in r2
which is this so so x and y are two
dimensional variables and we can compute
the integral of their scalar product
that's where this
okay now we got two implicit regions so
an implicit region is region defined as
a solution set of a condition so these
are all points in RN that satisfy
condition five phi and this is the
syntax is implicit region of phi and and
then the variables so here is a region
and we can plot it it takes about a
minute so we'll just show it the plot so
partner parametric region so it's region
given by a parametric a set of
parametric functions which with
parameters in RM either unrestricted
like this or we can have restrictions on
parameters so we can have
parameterization restrictions and
parameters and parameters so there are
two possible syntaxes for parametric
region so for instance this is a
parameterization given by x + y XY over
X Y belonging to a circle and we can
crisis discretize the region so this
will give a mesh region and it should
display it also so here this is the
image of a circle through this
parameterization so
now how do we decide point membership
for formula region again the same
function region member but there it's
for implicit region it's very easy to
decide membership because we it actually
contains membership conditions inside so
we can do it for symbolic point very
easily for parametric region that's that
that might be quite complicated because
we get parametrization so now if we want
to decide membership condition we need
to know whether this point is in the
image of this parameterization for this
set so in general this is a quantifier
elimination problem and if we give
symbolic coordinates then it potentially
can be very slow here it is fast spot
but potentially it can be very slow here
is slightly more complicated region now
we have to wait a couple of seconds to
the answer and as we can see the the
actual condition can be quite
complicated even though the region
didn't look that bad
dimension properties of formula regions
again we have embodying dimension which
is a dimension of the space in which the
region is embedded and then again for
all the region finally converting
remediate dimension is immediate it's
just a syntax check here for parametric
region it's the length of of this list
however computing the dimension of
region that requires non-trivial
computation for again for this region
it's easy why it's easy to find the
region dimension we well it's easy to
decide that dimension of this circle is
2 and this mapping happens to be one to
one that's that's one way why we can
easily compute the dimension of this set
but if if we give slightly more
complicated region well even for
implicit region computing dimension can
be can take some time and for parametric
region in general it's quantified
elimination so it's may be costly
now bounce for formula regions we have
the same two functions bounded region Q
and we can compute region bounds now
computing region bounds is solving a
system of constrained optimization
problems for each variables we have we
need to compute two optimization
problems why to compute so anyway this
is the plot of the region and we get a
bounding square for it but bounding
rectangle which happens to be square in
this case a distance properties can
compute we can compute region distance
region nearest for formula regions that
amounts to solving exact constrained
optimization problems and as we can see
the distance formula for the distance
can be quite complicated square root of
high-degree root object here already
here we get the nearest point also a
couple or three root objects
this took a while to compute so here it
is your point we have the nearest point
and the distance between them and this
is the region this is what we computed
here and so but we can also solve so for
basic region so I show that show the
example where where we computed region
distance and the region nearest where
the point and the region contains
symbolic parameters in principle it can
be done for for Formula regions but
that's very costly and it's W
explanation the number of parameters so
if I take a rather simple set in R 2 and
introduce 1 parameter I can get the
symbolic formula for for distance but if
I have a same regions and two parameters
it already is not finishing in five
minutes just a warning
symbolic formulas for distance and
nearest points that's mainly for the
basic regions measure properties for
formula regions that how do we compute
it it's we could decompose the regions
into cylindrical cells and then we run
integrate over each cylinder so the
cells are usually bounded by algebraic
functions and the success of the whole
computation depends on whether integrate
can handle there are genetic functions
that we get or not so for this region
the time you think everywhere actually
we integrate can handle it it takes a
while eventually yeah so here's the
measure of the region and let me just
show the centroid again it would take a
few seconds and it happened to be
centered at the origin so if we want to
compute the measure of a parametric
region then we have two places the
region comes with parameterization so we
can just do the change of variables in
integration and use the parameterization
but to to do this we have to be able to
prove that the parameterization is a
finite covering so that we it's either
one to one or and to one so that we can
divide the result by an which we know
with if we know the multiplicity of the
covering otherwise we would have to
compute the implicit representation so
quantify elimination and then go with
the implicit region in the integration
over the implicit region so here here's
an example where we actually can compute
the multiplicity of parameterization so
we - we can fit a single period of all
the sines and cosines into this
intervals 0 10 and then we can prove
that for the single period this is a
double covering of of the sphere
so we can compute the region measure of
the sphere and this was expected
expected so we can use the same method
of decomposing into three called cells
to to compute arbitrary integrals not
just measure and here is an example that
uses vector notation so X is a
three-dimensional vector I have a table
cell so it means that it took like 10 or
20 seconds to compute this and we have
parametric regions again we have the
same sign comments as I made before
about recognizing whether
parameterization is a finite covering or
not here we can do it this
parameterization is one-to-one
seen and here is the region over which
we just computed a integral x times y
now derived regions so we have at the
moment we have four four methods of
deriving new regions from already
constructed regions we can compute
boolean combinations of regions so it's
Union intersection different symmetric
difference and boolean region is
arbitrary boolean combination where the
first argument is a boolean function so
for instance here we have intersection
of two regions
here we can plot it I will just show the
plot it takes about a minute to compute
and membership conditions for a boolean
combination is obtained from boolean
combination of membership conditions for
component regions so that's easy if if
we can do it for component regions a
transformation of regions we have
transformed regions or inverse transform
the region so it's transformed regions
is an image of a region through a
transformation and inverse transform
region is inverse image of a region so
here this is a transformation of a disk
and we can plot it so this
transformation support the first
coordinates plus sum of squares and and
the product of coordinates this
transforms a region into triangle a disk
into a triangle and finding membership
conditions is quantified elimination so
we are looking to decide whether a given
point is in the image of a given mapping
and here it's really easy because we got
triangle s as the result and the inverse
transformation so it's in various
inverse image again of a disc through
through the very same transformation and
we got a triangle here which is oh I I
didn't evaluate it that's why I got
triangle so this is the inverse image of
these kids it's not a triangle it's it's
a region like this and the membership
conditions for inverse transparent
regions are really easy to obtain it you
just substitute to the transformation
functions into the membership conditions
for for the region we are transforming
so here the conditions that give this
region Cartesian product of regions so
here is product of a 2d region and in
interval we can plot it as expected
interval x times the region and we have
membership condition against there are
separate conditions for the first two
variables separate for for the last
variable because it was product
the topological boundary that that's we
have region boundary operator and four
basic regions we can actually compute it
explicitly or we have formulas give
explicit results so this is the boundary
of a simplex sorry no it's just just a
topological so it gives a region just
just no orientation information and
here's for ape side although you can see
that we start with with basic regions
here we have a boolean combination of
basic regions and here we have to go to
formula regions to describe the boundary
now another case where we can actually
return something for for region
boundaries where the region is not fully
dimensional then at the whole region is
the boundary that's about it third there
is say the last case is two dimensional
formula regions where we can where we
with we return unevaluated region
boundary but we can compute explicit
boundary conditions so you can see here
the region was described by very strict
inequality and the boundary is the set
described by equation minus one point so
it's not not that easy we can adjust
just go through from inequality to an
equation so like we can plot the the
region we started with so the the region
is to the right of of this curve but if
if we take the equation the solution of
equation is this curve and and one more
point we can see this using the color
composition so this gives the curve lot
but this there is one extra point
somewhere here
computing properties of derived regions
so this is a very similar picture to
what what I had before but now instead
of that tetrahedron I have a spiky which
is a union of tetrahedra and we can
compute distance easily because the
distance to a union is the minimum of
distances to all the components however
well you can see that I have only
distance here not know sign distance
computing sign distance to a union has
no is no relation to sign distance due
to the components and and actually
computing it to to this even 41.8 takes
a long time
symbolic computation over regions so we
start with so we have equations
inequality solving functions are reduced
so find instance resolve optimizations
or optimization functions work for over
regions we can compute integrals over
regions and we can use region element
something region as an assumption to xx
function that takes assumptions so
here's the first example find the
elements of a unit sphere that are
orthogonal to a given a pair of vectors
so the region is a sphere we have two
vectors and we would like to find
elements of the Spear sphere that are
orthogonal to those two vectors and we
can use vector notation so all UV and w
are our three dimensional vectors and we
get solutions that are given in this
format so vector variable goes to a
vector of numbers and here's a graphical
representation of it so we have we
started with two vectors and we computed
that two elements of sphere that are
orthogonal to these two vectors
now another problem find the projection
of a rotated for the hypercube onto ir3
so we start with with a hypercube in 4d
we rotate it and to compute the
projection we need to eliminate
quantifier so we compute reduce and
eliminate the quantifiers I mean the
last variable so this projection on the
first three variables and there is the
here what here's what we get this is a
projection of the rotated hypercube
again we could we could take the answer
from adduced just put it in pieces
regional and we got a region this finds
integer points in ellipsoid so we can we
can use regions with solving over
integers and again it's vector notation
so we get triples of integers here and
here's the website and the integer
points inside
now here's a slightly different type of
formulation of the problem now we have
parameters inside the regions and we are
solving for for those parameters so we
try to find this sphere passing through
four given points here's the solution
guess what it looks like on a picture
and we actually have a for this
particular problem we have a built-in
function so it says here comes fear of a
set of points gives the sphere that
passes through to these four points
so here let me describe what was
involved in in solving equations
inequalities over regions so we always
have to find an implicit description of
the region to do we even start solving
so for instance if we start with
parametric region we have to we have to
have the quantifier elimination step two
to even start the solving process and in
this case this works pretty fast so we
first compute conditions for this at the
equation solve the resulting thing and
here is the explicit parameter for
elimination problem that was solved so
the equation and this exists UV that are
in the image of parameterization so can
solve it if I fast and we can prove that
we got equivalent formulas
optimization we can we can use again
regions to specify optimization
constraints so here we optimize over a
unit ball in 4d and here's the maximum
now this finds the distance between
parabola and the line so the implicit
region here this is a parabola this
infinite line and we minimize norm of
two vectors or distance of two points
one of them is a parabola the other is
seen in the line we can use the vector
notation again so we get vectors
describing the minimum point and we got
the minimum value here's the picture so
we find find the minimum distance points
between a parabola and the line
and here's again we can we can also
optimize over parameters that are in the
description of the region so here we we
try to find the region that contains the
given points and it takes a while here
this
and we can see that in the digit
contains the five points three of them
are on the boundary two of them are
inside
okay so let me comment on on the methods
used so one constraint involve a single
parametric on or transformed region the
computing the implicit representation of
the region is not required so we can
just substitute the parameterization
into the objective function and optimize
over over the constraint support for the
parameter so here this is pretty fast
however if if we have two parametric
regions in the same problem so for
instance here is intersection of two
parametric regions then we have to
compute the implicit representation of
this intersection so this this may take
longer time to compute for this
particular case it's not so bad it's 1/2
second but now we computed the
intersection so if we optimize another
different function over the same
intersection now it's immediate because
the hard part was was getting the
implicit description of the region the
optimization part was was quite fast
here is picture of the 2 regions so we
have two curves and the intersection is
just a set of intersection points so
once we computed it the optimizing over
it is easy the computing part is hard
and finally we can use element X region
inside assumptions so here we simplify
element statement involving a region
over assumption that axis is in a
rectangle like this so this rectangle is
contained in a disk and we're probably
using simplify